Hey Thoughty2 here.
You don’t need to leave our planet to find
people who you can’t understand.
For some people, you don’t even need to
leave your own house; you’re still trying
to understand why your mum has suddenly outlawed
gluten and why your dad thinks video games
are the devil’s work but spent his whole
life playing with a model train set.
But, with some pointing and shouting at them,
you can at least manage to communicate on
a basic level.
But what about if we really came into contact
with an alien species; is it realistic to
think we could communicate and what form would
that take; speaking, writing, emojis?
We can look to the early explorers of our
planet, seeing how cultures collided, when
they met for the first time.
But at least they were of the same species,
things might not be so easy when you’re
trying to communicate with a creature that
has nipples for eyes and eyes where its nipples
should be.
Obviously our first problem is actually finding
some aliens to talk to us because it’s a
big old universe out there and I’m not sure
that Earth has made it into the galactic guidebook
yet, despite Ford Prefect’s best efforts.
It’s often said that the opening ceremony
to the 1936 Olympics was the first message
broadcast into space and there is some truth
to it.
It was at a high enough frequency that it
may have escaped the ionosphere and headed
off out the solar system.
But the likelihood that anyone would be able
to pick it up would be incredibly small because
it doesn’t have the power and concentrated
direction to get noticed, it would be lost
in the noise of the universe.
So thankfully, Hitler won’t be the first
face of mankind that the aliens see, you could
say, they will Nazi him coming.
We have made many intentional attempts both
to send messages and to listen out for them.
In August 1924, Mars was going to be closer
to Earth than at any point in the past century.
So, the US decided to have a good listen and
declared National Radio Silence Day where
all radios were silent for five minutes on
the hour, every hour.
They used an airship to lift a radio receiver
3 kilometres off the ground.
In 1962, the Soviets used the Pluton complex
in Ukraine to broadcast a Morse code message
towards Venus.
It was just three words; MIR, LENIN, SSSR.
‘Mir’ means both peace and world and SSSR
is the Russian for USSR.
Lenin was a good choice at the time but will
be unavailable to comment if the Venusians
do arrive.
So, let’s say we do get a message back,
it’s likely to be in the form of radio waves.
What do we do then?
The first thing is to try work out what each
part relates to.
If it’s mathematics then hopefully we will
know what to look out for; things like the
universal constants such as Pi, e, numbers
that occur throughout the universe.
If it’s language then it becomes much more
problematic since we don’t have some kind
of Rosetta Stone.
The Rosetta Stone was a carved rock found
in the town of Rosetta, Egypt, in 1799.
It was of incredible importance to our understanding
of ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs since it had
a trilingual inscription; hieroglyphs, Egyptian
script and Greek.
And this highlights our problem; without the
comparison to base our work off, it can be
impossible to ever make a translation of a
new language.
We don’t even need alien languages to test
this theory; there are plenty of untranslated
texts here on earth.
The Liber Linteus is a manuscript from around
250 BC, that was found wrapped around a mummy.
It’s one of the few examples of the Etruscan
language, from ancient Italy, and we’ve
barely managed to suss any of it out.
There’s also a language called Linear A,
from ancient Greek, that we’re struggling
with, despite it sounding like a Microsoft
Typeface from the 90s.
And there’s Proto-Elamite, used for a brief
200-year window in ancient Iran - we’ve
still no idea what they were up to and what
secrets these scripts hold.
Some linguists have thought that perhaps letting
language evolve naturally, with all it’s
weird quirks and local idiosyncrasies, is
not the best way to go about things.
English is taking over as the international
language, thanks largely to its dominance
over the internet, but attempts have been
made to create a universal language; which
would hopefully make life easier when aliens
join the action.
Kenneth Searight created Sona in 1935, in
response to some of the new constructed languages,
or conlangs as they are known, that were appearing;
like Esperanto.
His issue was that these new conlangs were
all very European focussed, which was not
truly global.
Sona was also agglutinative.
This basically means that when you connect
parts together, you don’t change the form
or sound or spelling – which is what most
languages do and all this fusing things together
makes them much more complicated.
Charles K Bliss, a Jewish concentration camp
survivor, tried to create a written pictogram
language, one that would be universal and
one that evil politicians could not manipulate,
leading to the horrors that he’d witnessed.
Although Blissymbols never spread around the
world, their logical structure was found to
be very useful in teaching disabled children
to communicate.
But we don’t know whether we will be speaking
or listening first when it comes to alien
communication.
So, in order to have our ears prepared for
alien arrival, Dr John Elliott of Leeds Metropolitan
University in England has designed a piece
of software that he hopes will be able to
tell what is and isn’t a language and, if
it is, what patterns it contains.
Finding out what form the message is in will
be the key.
If you get a jpeg from the stars but you think
it’s music, it’s going to be difficult
to decipher the message, although you will
probably make a fortune as a pioneering new
techno artist.
You can just see hipsters lapping that up.
The voyager probes, that we sent out into
the depths of our solar system, both carry
a gold disc which plays like a record.
The back cover dedicates a lot of space to
explaining how to play the record and how
to extract the information; since there is
music, sounds and images.
We used pictures of hydrogen atoms to define
the time scale since they are the most common
element and their state change is a universal
constant.
There was also a diagram of how to play the
record.
But, given the fact that half a page of Ikea
instruction drives most of us to madness,
I’m not holding out too much hope for
the aliens.
Thanks for watching.